he was always kind U you know I think he
was a good man um I don't know that he
was good at being a man you know
especially in his later years with the
way that he's sort of like you know
fizzled out like that but um he you know
he was he was certainly an enjoyable
character and um somebody that sort of
did his own thing and and marched the
beat of his own drum he never tried
to as far as I know really have
conversations with or integrate with
anybody in the Mano swamp there were
people that worked in the Mano swamp
that really hated him though for some
reason I don't know why I think it was
more because of Envy or jealousy because
they were like oh he's you know he's a
grifter and you know he doesn't belong
there and it's like I've always
said you know wisdom comes from
experience and you want to listen to
older guys when it comes to
conversations and topics and you know
the Notions of the challenges that young
men deal with in the world today and I
saw a lot of young inexperienced posers
in the man of swamp you know pretending
or holding out that they were um
experienced or knowledgeable and because
he got such good reach with his his
videos and the way that they were edited
and distilled you to the point I think
that um there might have been a little
bit of envy and jealousy there but he
was he was really really fascinating
dude to have conversations with so rest
in peace uh Gonzalo lero he was uh he
was fascinating man um I strongly
encourage you to all go back to his
archives and watch some like like his
older videos in you know the CRP and I
hope somebody out there if you have
access to all of his videos and even his
patreons you know stuff like that um you
know share it you know let other people
see it because I think there's some uh
decent conversations and questions to be
asked uh he was he was a curious
character so that's how I would sum him
up anyway um I think I'll wrap it up on
that note um you guys you know chop it
up in the the chat and leave some
comments and you know you let me know
what you think again if you want to see
those oh there's a few super chats here
let me get those in a second if you want
to see the public conversations that I
had with him um just search this YouTube
channel with either coach redpill and or
Gonzalo L I think there's there's
definitely one there might be two or
three conversations that I've had with
him over the years but go check him out
um he was fun to talk to let me check
these super chats here it was inevitable
that he was going to get killed there he
was spreading too much truth on the
war yeah rip
CRP and Chuck says I know a bunch of
people in the sphere didn't like him but
when I discovered the red pill five six
years ago he was one of the guys who got
me to open my eyes spoke himself to
death but the man was uh but was a man
of his words um yeah he spoke himself to
death yeah there's yeah there's no doubt
about that he uh he did so there's a
legacy of his um coach red pill videos I
think which are which are probably the
best place to um sort of remember and um
reminisce of some of the conversations
you have because I think
like a lot of the stuff on YouTube a lot
of it is just filler and his stuff was
like n910 I don't think I don't think
anybody me inclusive does 10 1010 but I
think he was like a you know he was
right up there and one of the few
channels that I would um watch on a
regular basis just because they were
useful consistent short distilled they
were just good and entertaining um you
know the way that they were edited so
check them out I really hope you guys
enjoyed that clip if you want to watch
the full length podcast you can find
that over here that clips from if you're
new to the channel make sure you hit
subscribe over here and pin down below
in the top comment you'll find a bunch
of useful links to my website my
supplement line books and a bunch of
other stuff have an amazing day peace
out